is there like a is it like
was there an old medieval method of
determining what's poisonous or not or
was it just give it to some poor side
by fire was it was it really yeah i've
always i've always thought about this
like i must have just had one rich guy
who was like well
random a bunch of the people who can't
afford much i mean how do you think they
how do you think people discovered like
what mushrooms were poisonous
there's no tragic though you're just
like oh hi what's your job well i'm a
poison tester i'm through for three at
the moment
tomorrow will go well like you know what
blows my mind how the [ __ ]
did like people in japan figure out
which part of the puffer fish wasn't
poisonous
like how many people had to die to know
the exact methods but why also
did someone die they were like gonna try
it okay
one more time guys guys guys we're 100
to zero
on the pufferfish right now but maybe
yeah maybe there's one time
there has to be somewhere on this thing
that's edible right like after you find
out
something is poisonous i think it's okay
to give up
and not eat it you know that's what i
thought like
is it like like we got to make sure the
last guy might have like you know side
effects yeah yeah like beforehand
have you had the puffer fish yeah a
couple of times
i've heard it's very underwhelming yeah
i heard it it's not great listen if i'm
gonna die
i want it to be not worthy right like i
want the wrist to be worth the reward
yeah of course and it just looks like
really shitty like um
like sushi what's up what does it even
what does it even taste like
nothing that's what i've actually tasted
that's what i've heard
it's just grown men wanting to die yeah
it's lit no it's literally just a status
symbol
it's to just say that you've had a
pufferfish because i've seen the videos
and i'm just like this just looks like
you're eating
like [ __ ] cardboard you know it
tastes like it doesn't it doesn't look
like you're
like actually you do know what it tastes
like the soy sauce that you dip it in
that's what it tastes like i i love
unagi
is one of my favorite japanese dishes
yep and i found out
if you cook it incorrectly it's [ __ ]
poisonous yeah no one told me that
that's what's it that's why it's so
expensive
it's it's poisonous as [ __ ] it can kill
you you know i'll [ __ ] risk it
that's one thing i will risk yeah yeah
because it [ __ ] slaps and then i was
like you know what this ad the element
of danger adds to the taste now
frankly but if it's if it's not very
good tasting i feel that's why a lot of
people eat puffer fish as well it's like
the element of danger adds to the taste
whatever
they're tasting i don't know
do you reckon there's a guy out there
just like god kill me
if it's this time around like i'm pretty
sure that's like
whoever like you know it's i i get it
right because you know when you see like
poisonous berries
yeah i still really want to try them
like because they look so delicious
when you're a kid yeah and the you cakes
there's so many poisonous berries is
that
that's how nature [ __ ] with you dude
yeah the ones that look the most
delicious
yeah yeah yeah because i like those
bright little red things you know you
see them
yeah oh okay that looks so [ __ ]
delicious
they look like like mini tomatoes all
right i just want to have a
get a bunch of those and just see what
happens you know
that's probably how that's probably how
people found out they were poisonous
right well i get it i mean okay
okay let's say you know you haven't got
much food you know you struggling all
right you go to that you have to wander
through the forest
whatever you see a bunch of you see a
bush enough food for the family
what do you do enough food to kill the
family nobody told you they're
poisonous you know yeah like also who
who got poisoned by a mushroom was like
no no no it was supposed to be this type
of mushroom and goes out and tries
another one
that's like a very bold thing like who's
doing this well someone had to right so
someone did it back in the day it must
have been people with too much money
being like
i will literally pay you a thousand
dollars like literally like a mistake
like when's the mr beast video coming
out where he's like i pay people
one hundred thousand dollars to try
mushrooms to find out which one's
poisonous
how much shitake mushroom will kill you
eat mushrooms last one to survive wins a
million dollars
everyone gets those i don't know if you
want people to do it just make it a
[ __ ] tick tock challenge yeah yes
so i found this mushroom in my cupboard
tik tok mushroom challenge let's get the
death cap challenge
[Laughter]
today i'm eating a death cap hope if i
survive oh my god
you know i think i would rather try my
luck eating a poisonous mushroom
and just try my chance of surviving as
opposed to putting my hand on my iphone
for four days
you know for that keep your hand on the
iphone oh yeah oh
that way i think i would actually rather
poison myself than do that for four days
that sounds [ __ ] horrible yeah i know
i'm sure the pain would be over within
two days if you just get to go to the
hospital get it all sorted just be fine
get slight arthritis you'll be all right
i mean it's not a bad one you know i'm
sure there's i'm sure there's mushrooms
out there just make you like
very much vomit i'm i'm yeah
yeah probably sure which one would you
would you rather vomit profusely for
like four hours or would you rather put
your hand on an iphone
for four hours and you can't sleep i
mean i probably you mean four days it's
like four days four days yeah four hours
that's very easy
have you ever tried to stay up past like
one day dude like it
how long's how how long is the longest
you've stayed up like a damn day and a
half
for me for me it's like 36 hours yeah
yeah yeah yeah 36 hours
and that's where it starts to get like
[ __ ] weird yeah like your brain
starts to like want to [ __ ] like turn
off
yeah definitely so like and i feel like
by the third day
what on earth is going through your head
like i couldn't do that and
that's why i would rather eat the
[ __ ] mushrooms that might poison me
maybelline can you google it is there
any mushrooms that'll just make me throw
up a little bit
like a little like not kill me but like
is this like is this an option i just
want to make sure
i mean i wouldn't want to do either
personally but personally both
sounds like hell but uh someone's going
to come up with they'll be like now it's
the mushroom cleanse
you know this mushroom this mushroom
will detox your body yes it's making you
[ __ ]
lose it all that's what they're doing
man
oh my god mascarine muscari mascara what
does it make you do
for i guess 15 after 15 30 minutes
you'll start getting like
diarrhea and decreased blood pressure oh
wow
that that sounds pretty bad oh that
sounds yeah that sounds pretty bad if
you're vomiting but you recover within
24 hours
that's good then brilliant what was it
called again uh
[Music]
we are just joking around please don't
do that um it's only ten percent less
deadly than the cinnamon challenge so
it's pretty it's okay